[Musique]
pense que c'est un sentiment très
important dans la vie l'amitié jean
michel ben oui parce que sinon ben on
s'ennuie à beaucoup si on n'aurait pas
admis
enfin ça deviendra impossible quoi et
toi le rang
[Musique]
les aider
quand chez nous
bah oui comment ça s'est passé je vais
je peux jouer malgré tout l'été
alors c'est devenu un ami mais on
n'avait pas de limites ils nous sont une
erreur puis sur l'oreille l'occasion
voir des amitiés et sur l'art est mort
quand leur avion bord et comment tu sors
quelqu'un va devenir ton amie sylvie si
la première est maintenant aussi fait
déçoit qu'est ce que tu feras je sais
que c'est vrai
et toi corinne je trouve je pense quand
même 10 très important parce que si
personne pouvait s'entraîner je trouve
que la vie sera plausible c'est une
personne qui nous perdra jamais vu
tu seras une plupart du temps avec lui
quand il en aura le temps e
il fera bien quand même des sacrifices
et tu l'as trouvé cette personne je ne
sais pas tu ne sais pas je crois très
difficile alors d'avoir un meilleur
oui moi c'est difficile bernard est ce
que tu as un meilleur ami julien du oui
tu fais la différence entre un ami un
copain oui parce qu'un ami il est plus
avesnois un copain qu est ce qu un
copain eu lieu dans la cour et s'occupe
de nous juste quand il nya récré un ami
je t'avais dit vouloir à la récréation
et toi sophie tu as un meilleur ami une
meilleure allure elle est toujours avec
moi ajouté jean avec un jour pourquoi tu
l'a choisi c'est la première que je
connais et tu la verras toujours quand
tu seras grande tu crois que cette
amitié va vous suivre vous ils sont
je sais pas pourquoi tulle m
si parce que les gens tu ignorais gère
un peu d'amitié pour elle et toi tu es
gentil avec elle
parce que je suis arrivé en cours
d'année comme ça parce qu'elle il a tout
de suite a été gentil avec moi tout de
suite ça a été mon premier copain mais
tu es sûr que c'est ton meilleur ami ont
pratiquement jean nadeau
oui j'ai vu hier soir et jusqu'au bout
c'est parce que au début et l'état à
côté de moi en classe le jeu m'a aidé à
travailler et déjanté c'est quoi être
plus gentils au bas mot z enfin il
partage toujours ce qu'il a comme du
bonbon par exemple il n'est joué avec
avec lui qu'est ce qui fait que tu as
tiré par quelqu'un d'autre part
quelqu'un plus que par quelques années
et bien parce que ce seul celui là est
ma il m'a pas quitté quand quand comme
les autres parce que les autres ainsi si
l'on meurt deux mois il semble quant à
lui reste c'est un seul clic
une famille par exemple ce nouveau
camion quand on n'arrive pas à faire
quelque chose quoi parce que les yeux
pour le remarque pourquoi ils sont
gentils avec le sympathique vite ce
n'est pas quoi en faire quelque chose ne
se fait pas je leur lis beaucoup
d'ennemis en fait jamais de particules
garçons ou filles ont dit les deux thés
différents et sentiments non la reine
c'est très différent les plus fous je
trouve à nous un garçon est généralement
plus timide
vous vous dites tous n'ont pas forcément
ya des choses que tu dit au garçon n'est
pas la fille inversement
oui des fois pourquoi ce ton meilleur
ami je peux pas me dire on se connaît
depuis longtemps on a reviré
et puis on a à peu près les mêmes
caractères moi mon avis c'est parce
qu'on a à peu près le même les mêmes
sentiments on allume ave un peu les
valider c'est pour ça on n'a lui pas
forcément les mêmes idées les mêmes
goûts mais surtout le même caractère
pour voir si ce sont deux voisins
amicaux c'est qu'on est dans la
malchance parce que qu'on eut la
malchance beaucoup ne quitte et c'est le
meilleur qui nous vient en mousse vient
en aide si un jour où tu dois t'en
allaient quitter paris et que tu ne le
vois plus tu seras malheureux emerson
j'espère que quand vous serez des hommes
continuent à vous voir oui parce que lui
il va dans le même
ces vagues condorcet même si mes des
années parce qu'on a pu on se perdra de
vue après tant qu'on ne sera pas dans ma
miss et on trouvera d'autres amis les
relations se feront quoi papa que tu
essaieras de les voir quand même si le
plus possible mais à la fin ça se perd
jamais su oh oui oh je crois qu'on
espère gratuit pourquoi
[Musique]
parce que vos amis en année on connaît
votre fai sai on ne sait rien ne vient
[Musique]